[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
cart rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host today we're
going to talk about your relationships
we're going to talk about you we're
going to talk about your work we're
going to talk about your money
we're going to talk about all of it it's
god's and grandma's ways of doing life
it's called the ramsay show the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five the call is free and
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it triple eight eight
two five five two two five luke is gonna
start off this hour in detroit hey luke
what's up
hey everybody thanks for taking my call
sure man
yup so i'm 28 years old and looking to
purchase my first house and i'm calling
i'm wondering if i should include things
like stock compensation and yearly bonus
in my total compensation when figuring
out
what a budget for a house would be yes
okay yeah 25 percent 25 of your
take-home pay annually regardless of
where it comes from bottom line is do
you have money
to pay the house payment
at a fourth of your hou income and still
have money left over to live life well
that's what this is it's not a it's not
like some kind of nuanced thing that if
you're off three tenths of a percent uh
on your uh ratios or something that
you're going to go broke that's not the
thing the point is don't buy a stinking
house where your house pays 50 of your
take-home pay you ain't got any money
and you're gonna end up taking out a car
payment when the car breaks
got it yeah i was more kind of concerned
with
including things like stock and even
side gigs really just because of it's
like the stock tanks i mean you were
kind of depending on getting one chunk
of it well if it's a big portion of i
mean if it's 50 of your income then i'd
be worried about it but it's not it's
five percent
got it so if you got zero it doesn't
change your life and you'll probably get
it the next year
got it and your income is going to go up
after you buy the house too
over time
agreed okay
yep yeah so that's the other thing the
whole thing about the 25 of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed rate
ratio is just simply to keep you from
getting yourself strapped to the wall
all in the name of oh god i live in
california and math doesn't count here
or stuff like that right of course it
counts there math works everywhere and
so it keeps you from getting emotional
and doing some stupid butt thing because
you you figured out that's the only
house in the whole world that you can
live in or something that's what the
ratio is for is to make you think
clearly and instead of using the
emotional side
of your brain because we all use the
emotional side of our brain when making
uh financial decisions and they seldom
work john never works man i we bought a
house last year that that that ratio
provided a great anchor for us like just
a place to stay tethered into
and
we searched for nine months and the
housing prices were escalating the whole
time and then the the people were
getting more and more dramatic but
always knowing let's let's this is our
this is our anchor point here man that
provided so much stability it provided
me and my wife a place like almost like
home base we could always go back to and
say we're gonna stay here you know and
it that's what it is that's what the
stuff we give you guys out there these
guidelines we give you these steps we
give you and everything else is an
anchor point it just goes okay here's
where common sense is to the extent
you're not lined up with that
you're probably about to make a mess
bubba i mean that's all we're saying
right so for me it's simple i don't
borrow money for anything right so my
anchor point is do i have the money
that's i have to start there right
dave how is that how is that crazy i
mean isn't that weird it's what i have
to start with well i mean and it gets
big and my world has gotten big like we
just bought a piece of ground next doors
you know
a bazillion millions of dollars right 22
acres next door over here and for for
the for this complex this ramsay
freaking campus thing going but even
that i'm looking at this massive and
it's a nice investment it's a great real
estate investment in a wonderful area
and i'm thrilled we did it but you know
winston rachel says one does our real
estate we're sitting there looking at it
and we had to ask ourselves like we're
in
uh like we're in the
grocery store line we want to buy a pack
of gum you know do we have the money
right and uh if we don't the answer is
we can't even look at this deal
there's something brilliant about the
complexity of that you know how rare it
is that i'm speechless and i'm
speechless at the idea
that it sounds crazy to think as a
business owner of a
multi-million dollar corporation to
think
do i have the cash to pay for that
and that just sounds that that puts you
in the i bet there's one percent of one
percent of business owners in the
country that run their machines like
that but you know what the other thing
is it does and it does it in your
personal life it does it in whatever
you're doing whatever it is you're doing
there's just
a lot of peace yeah
in that simplicity yeah and um and you
know people make fun of me you know you
don't understand this you're not
sophisticated and i'm like crap man i
can pencil whip all of you that say that
stuff i understand the other stuff but i
also understand how i feel
when a pandemic hits and i don't have
any payments oh anybody anything yeah
you know i also understand that i always
seem to have money
because i don't have any payments you
know it's just these are kind of basic
stuff you know but it there's a
cleanliness to it of the soul yeah of
your spirit um i mean you talk a lot
about trauma on your show and even calls
that come in here and in the books and
things and uh uh you know it's there's a
thing i guess we need to do a book
someday on financial trauma absolutely
what it does to you to stay geared up
wired up jacked up all the time about
your freaking life because you bought a
bunch of crap you can't afford with
money you don't have to impress people
you don't really like this is a bad
chemistry it does stuff to the body i'm
learning from you it melts you from the
inside out it's like it's like dumping
drano down your sink once a year to get
a hair clog out
it's not great but it's fine but if
every morning you just get up and dump
drano down your sink just to dump draino
down your sink because that's just the
way i live it's gonna eat through the
pipes it'll rot your pipe that's right
don't make a mess man some of you got
rotten pipes and you know i live that
way because you're just living from
stress to stress right it's like being
you know in poor control of your time
christie's book take back your time when
you t when you take back your time and
you take back your money
man
just a lot of peace you know i was
reading the book a couple of months ago
david was talking about
um some ways to
just live a little more peacefully
and one of the things that suggested was
this
just for the next week drive the speed
limit
oh now you're going to meddling no
listen man
i tried to drive the speed limit
i thought i was just walking no that's
not peaceful for me that's quite the
opposite no but listen i did it for a
week just just just to prove it and i
tell you what i got to work
i had to leave a little bit earlier a
lot earlier a lot lot earlier but i got
to work and you had no fun i wasn't
frazzled
i didn't feel like i was
being electrocuted it was just again
it's a different way to do life i think
that we have sped up the world so fast
so quickly so with so much bonkers
advice we don't even know what feeling
good feels like if you never turned on
the news for the next 10 days
at all at all it's all going to happen
anyway
yes
and and if you're just going to feel
so much somebody will text you so much
better hey listen just tune in here if
something big is going on we'll tell you
but we're probably not going to bring it
up so because there's not much big
enough for it to make in the news cycle
for it to make it to this show because
we're a big deal and we don't really
want to talk about that stuff this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today we all know the story of
the tortoise and the hare and we all
know who wins the slow guy the slow and
steady guy but we gloss over the
downfall of the hair he didn't lose
because he was slower he lost because he
took a nap
if you're starting to lose steam this is
your wake-up call we want 2022 to be
your best wealth building year ever we
want you to build wealth
for a limited time we got all kinds of
life changing books and tools included
in our ten dollar
our famous ten dollar sale ten dollar
books could be your best return on
investment get it
uh get your books uh get books like our
number one bestseller the total money
makeover dr john deloney's quick read
redefining anxiety all for ten bucks
rachel cruz's latest best seller new
york times know yourself know your money
on sale for only 10 bucks make 2022 your
best wealth building year
get it at ramseysolutions.com
10 sale ramsey solutions dot com merry
merry christmas robertson atlantic city
hey robert welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave hello john
hey what's up you on the show sure i'm
going to help try to make this quick
i've been going back and forth with uh
with my wife about this for a couple
days my son passed away
uh recently
and
because we filed a baby steps we had a
fully funded emergency fund and were
able to pay for the all the funeral
expenses out of pocket oh god robert how
old was he
18. what in the world happened yeah
it was a freak accident from what the
police said uh he was getting his car
worked on
the uh i don't know why or how they
turned the car on in the garage
him and the mechanic died of carbon
monoxide no
oh my goodness
this was just this past saturday oh lord
robert i'm so sorry
the 11th
i'm so sorry
yeah me too
what was his name so you had an
emergency fund you said so yeah and uh
the fully funded mercy fund we paid for
everything in cash um you know first day
when we went to do the funeral romanians
but um
i never lost anyone close to me so i
don't know how this stuff works
but um donations
checks and contributions started coming
in i assume to help with the expenses
and
it you know it turns out you know we
didn't need it and so now i'm going back
and forth with my wife like what do we
do now because a lot of people
contributed maybe thinking
you know we needed it and we actually
didn't so i'm i'm kind of you know what
do we do now do we give it back
you know um
and not only that um i have life
insurance and he's a rider on the policy
and
after everything goes through um
if if it goes through um it's twenty
five thousand dollars on on him for the
uh rider on the policy
so on top of the uh already having the
money now i'm probably gonna receive
this twenty five
much money
did you how much money did you receive
from friends um probably uh
probably close to ten thousand
okay what was the largest
donation
uh 2500
okay
man
well my wife she says maybe we should
just pay it forward and i said i mean
that's fine yeah and
in the meantime i'm like
i don't know i'm going back and forth
but i don't know what to do
yeah
well here's the thing
um
when a horrible tragedy like this
happens um
we we try to find something we can do to
feel like we're doing something and this
is your thing you're trying to find
something to do with
um and my point of telling you that is
man it don't matter what you do with
this money
it does it's ten thousand dollars it
doesn't matter uh you're there's not a
wrong thing people gave it to you the
goodness of their hearts their hearts
are broken with you they were trying to
find something to do too yeah they were
trying to find something to do and if
you wanted to call the largest donor
and just say man i don't need the money
i'm willing to return it to you or i'm
willing to pay it forward you tell me
what to do with it but i and i
appreciate that because you know who
that largest one is at 2500 the rest of
them i'm with your wife i just
i just mix it into your life
and your life is going to be
a generous life after this like it has
never been before
you'll never see someone in that kind of
a situation but what you won't react for
the rest of your life because you have
that
that broken heart
in this area of your life
robert what was your son's name
jake jake and he was 18.
18. he was going to marines uh today
basic training started today wow
my recommendation is to sit on this for
three to six months yeah okay i want you
just to put an account somewhere and
hang on to it
out of nowhere
you're gonna be doing something or get
connected to a marine who's coming home
who needs some support or who wants to
go to school or wants to do a thing
there's gonna be somewhere where you can
bless somebody with this in a way that
would honor the memory of jake
and will give you one not a
not a full step but two inches of a step
in a direction towards making meaning of
this nonsense of this madness
and it will
give you just a little bit of light
but right now you're feeling like you
got to do a thing and um
i wouldn't do anything
there's no big moral statement that
needs to be made here now yeah the thing
is too um you know we live a good life
you know we we travel quite a bit you
know we do things i just i just have
this overwhelming guilt
to live my life and can continue to live
in the way we live and then people look
from the outside like well we just gave
you money help with the funeral now
if there's
just go ahead and holler at them and
send them the money back but that's why
i said you might want to call the big
one but let me just tell you 99.9
percent of people that donate that gave
you stuff they just gave it because they
were heartbroken too and they just
wanted to do something and that guilt is
mis is misallocated you're hurting about
your boy
you're feeling it all over the place i
just reverse it for a second let's say
you gave somebody a thousand bucks you
didn't know if they had the money for
the funeral but you just saw the
horrible thing and you gave somebody a
thousand bucks
and then three weeks three months later
you see them on vacation what'd you
think
no i wouldn't think anything that's
you're most people man you'd say i'm so
glad they got to get away yeah they
needed it their hearts are broken
yeah that's what my wife said she says
the same thing yeah you're worrying
about stuff you don't need to worry
about
everything's spinning around brother
yeah you're just everything's uh the
world's upside down
because your your heart's got destroyed
and so just
yeah
as a matter of fact i might go so far as
to say um
in a month or two um i might allocate
some of this money for just to get away
weekend for you and your wife in the
mountains
or wherever it is the beach or wherever
it is you guys go and just
and you don't have to do anything but
just sit there and cry but you get away
from all the people and the craziness
and the story and the
visuals that remind you and of jake and
everything else and just get away
somewhere and just spend a weekend just
in a pile kind of just in in a crying
pile you know what i'm saying and just
um
you know you use some of the money for
that and you know
god knew what you needed at this time
and he sent this this little bit of
money
and it ain't much the 25 000 is that's a
different thing that's obviously life
insurance and you just put that wherever
you are in your baby steps and don't
blink just move right along
it just happens to be associated with
jake sometimes folks will take that and
start some kind of a little uh
ministry or some kind of a little or
make a donation in jake's name out of
that money to something
uh maybe to uh
you know maybe to a veteran's cause or
um you know wounded warriors or
something somebody like that and reach
and help you know folk marines
that he was going to be and you know you
may want to do something like that just
just um
but all of that falls on the heading
your wife said and that's pay it forward
and and it's okay to do nothing and not
worry about this right now
yeah and we're entering the a season of
you guys were gonna have a last
christmas together and you're gonna tell
them goodbye and you had a whole thing
planned here i want you to
with your wife with your with your small
group of family and friends that you
count on for those type of moments i'd
love for y'all to con to go ahead and do
it anyway
if everybody wrote a letter to jake and
a goodbye letter here's what we're going
to miss about you here's what we loved
about you
can be a great moment of private healing
um as you head into this christmas
holiday christmas will never be the same
in your family and it doesn't have to be
a bad thing but it's gonna be a
different thing
and um well that part of thinking and
praying for you that part of it is bad
yeah but john always says grief demands
a witness and so being being community
through the holidays here with this
horrible event i'm so sorry man
i'm so sorry
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage nico
and alexis are with us hey guys how are
you merry christmas hey
merry christmas good to have you guys
where do you live we live in atlanta
georgia all right well welcome to
nashville how much debt did you pay off
we paid off 460 thousand dollars
what how long did this take it took us
47 months all right and your range of
income during that time we went from
about 200 000 to 300 000. good lord what
do you guys do foreign
are you
hiring well
i'm a general dentist and i work in
cyber security oh i guess you do okay
you're crushing it wow congratulations
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding so what kind of debt was the 4600
dollars so credit cards start student
loans and two cars
whoa yeah big student loans huge student
loans who had the big student loans
the dentist dentist yes yes
200 or 300 000 yep right around that
yeah
yeah and um
wow how old are you gosh i'm 33 i'm 32.
a 32 year old debt-free dentist you know
what that is that's a unicorn it doesn't
exist i know you're so weird
awesome you are awesome weird i love it
okay how long you all been married
well we got married february 2018 so
we're going on four years
okay so you start on this immediately
yeah right away get married get out of
dental school maybe yes yeah at the same
time and game all yes okay so what made
you know to do this i mean how did you
get connected to ramsay because you guys
i mean you didn't just start you went
boom
yeah so it started with me i think i was
going to get my master's program
and i was taking out more loans and then
paying back my old loans and she told me
she said that's dumb just stop doing
that you look like a dog
and so it clicked for me at that point
that i said you know what why not just
get all of my student um my master
program done then we're just gonna get
focused on the old loans then we just
decided to get married went to the
courthouse and said we're not having a
wedding so we say we plan 25 000 wedding
scratch that whoa because it's too much
debt so that jump started our whole life
right there it was just that big
decision right there i think changed our
life
wait a minute your whole life you dream
of having a wedding is a little girl
guys don't give a rip
no guys go oh no no wedding but girls i
mean it's like since you were playing
dolls with little barbies
you know and then you just had no
wedding how'd that feel
um well it was worth the sacrifice but
like you said i i had my wedding cake
planned out when before i even knew nico
so i i knew
what i wanted to do i knew i wanted
it was hard it was but it was so worth
it like
because we know that when we are
debt-free and we all the money that we
have is ours we can plan a five-year
celebration or a ten-year celebration if
we want to
but we shouldn't
know this we should have wheeled in a
wedding cake yeah
like right now in front of them you
should because she that's what you need
you need to go home buy a wedding she's
a dentist she wouldn't have eaten it
i eat sweets
those cakes are pure sugars
not good for you yeah oh my gosh that is
a hard thing to do to walk away from
something that you've thought about like
that
in order to hit a larger goal but you
get married you're game on right yeah
yeah yeah definitely but you had cayman
spoke at our church in atlanta um
elizabeth baptist oh yeah dr craig
oliver yeah i love him he is awesome
he's become a good friend yeah that was
the first time we had like seen you in
person and it was just so inspiring to
hear your your talk so that kind of lit
the fire under us to get started yeah
man that is so stinking cool way to go
man and that was about that long ago
yeah it was about four years ago or five
times away in a heart feel like it was
yesterday but but it wasn't who had the
first hard conversation with who the one
that said what if we just skipped the
wedding and what if we sold one of these
cars and what if
well i think i i kind of played it i
said we can do the wedding but it's
going to take us longer to pay off the
debt and we ended up buying a house so i
told her the house was going to have to
wait
so it was kind of uh i guess she kind of
said let's get the house and let's go
ahead and start paying off and then i'll
get the wedding later but i did get the
the ring that i wanted so that was
another compromise it was like you know
you get this this is a fair trade for 25
grand
absolutely ought to be a little
negotiation in there
i'm so proud of y'all incredible yeah
you are you're a rock star i mean you're
making 300k at 30 years old you know but
payments right no dad
you're just whacked this is so cool
very very neat what a power couple very
cool all right now you heard me do the
talk four years ago you got fired up and
you went and did this people they're
just joining in for the very first time
that i have no idea what you and i are
talking about
what do you tell someone the secret to
paying off 460
000 worth of debt in 47 months is
i think it's all about having a plan and
just staying focused it's so easy to get
distracted it's you know you can get
into real estate you can try to do
crypto so our key was let's just focus
on one thing and then we'll worry about
everything later and i think that just
kind of helped us stay focused and not
get distracted too much
you know there's a lot of get rich quick
out there right now right and to to be
the tortoise instead of the hair is
really hard right now yeah
and but you guys took a wise route
because now you have control of not
crypto or real estate but
your most powerful wealth building tool
with the highest
based on our data the highest indicator
of becoming wealthy which is i've gotten
rid of 460 000 with a dad yeah you're
beautiful man you know what else you got
that that all the bitcoin chasers don't
have peace money oh yeah you have money
you can sleep at night actually you have
real money that you can yeah hold and
touch and see it's because it's yours
right oh my goodness absolutely
incredible this is uh this is absolutely
fine have you had your first
dentist paycheck that just deposited and
you had no payments just this past
friday i got my first one so yeah
what do we do with this
merry christmas yes yes i had my first
one and i was like i can't believe that
student loan payment is not coming out
where's all this money man where's all
this money been we were giving it all to
them we absolutely were
sally may her eviction notice absolutely
you're listening to this
go watch this on youtube but i just
mentioned that y'all smiled so big here
here man yeah because we're we're
planning a trip so next year we're going
right now it's dubai oh
wow we're thinking about taking this
time next year so baker go home yeah
right
and hey you're the nico you're the
you're the most smiley
web security guy i've ever met in my
life
this is freedom i'm looking at man oh
yeah yeah congratulations dentists are
supposed to be smiling yeah that's part
of the gig right yeah all right all
right who is your biggest cheerleader
outside the two of you
well we have a ton of friends and family
who've been there for us
what comes on top of my head my
hygienist norma she is someone who has
been my biggest cheerleader she's doing
her debt-free journey now she is on her
last student loan payment herself and it
just the time aligned that we were both
done at the same time as well so
um i would say miss norma my hygienist
yeah and i would say two of my best
friends they call me all the time
cheering me on and they're in their
journey now too so it just helps having
people to relate to cool well a whole
bunch of folks at your church went
through financial piece at a time yeah
when i was down there i know that yeah
so yeah with dr oliver that's pretty
impressive cool guys
very cool we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you it comes out
january in just a few weeks comes out
january the 11th what is that about two
weeks now and uh from now but we're
going to give you an early copy i know a
guy
hook you up because you're going to be
baby steps millionaires before you know
it uh with a 300 000 income and no
payments it doesn't take long but we're
talking like wednesday
like next wednesday when we get back
from dubai
yes yes game on and a copy of total
money makeover for you to give away
because as you're talking about your
journey somebody out there will be going
what and you can pay it forward and kind
of give them their little wake-up call
and man i am so honored that i got to be
there at your church and now i get to
meet somebody four years later and this
is where you are that's thrilling to me
that's worth the trip to atlanta right
there just for that and uh very very
cool
good stuff good stuff nico and alexis
atlanta georgia paid off 460 and 47
months making 200 to 300 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that man touchdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
courtney is in indianapolis hi courtney
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks so much thank you how
can we help
yeah my husband is transitioning to a
new job next month it's in a new field
and um i just would like some help
trying to figure out how to set up our
monthly budget and some of the specifics
about 401k and um
yeah the just getting our we have to
start allocating our benefits pretty
soon and i
i'm not entirely sure like how to set up
our new budget because i don't know
exactly what the take-home pay is going
to be
the catch is that he's going to he's
making a little bit less money with this
new job
why
um well he wanted to
i mean in the simplest of terms he
didn't really have a feature at his
current company due to the mandate so he
kind of saw the writing on the wall and
so he decided to get out while the game
was good okay so he had to kind of
switch fields
the good news is his new new job is 100
remote and it's based out of texas so we
feel like we have a little bit of
security there
uh has upside
yeah the upside is that it's it's remote
so then the upside is he's not gonna get
fired for vaccines but but but i mean is
there a career ladder upside
yeah so i mean definitely very he's kind
of start at the bottom again um but the
trajectory it looks really good and you
know the current job i mean he wasn't
allowed to go into the corporate office
so yeah
there wasn't i mean his future there was
kind of over yeah i understand okay
um the uh
we're getting a lot of people joining
ramsey some really high quality people
joining ramsey for the same reason they
you know they reach the end of their
um time with their other company based
on their
uh policies and so forth so yeah it's
it's a lot of people looking for another
place to work and um all right now the
uh did it
you're out of debt except and you have
your emergency fund
yeah we actually we we moved earlier
this year and we um we bought a new home
and so we have we have a pretty sizable
nest egg now but we're completely out of
debt except for our mortgage okay all
right very good
all right so you'll be putting 15
percent of your income into 401k right
so his company will match 36 percent of
six percent of the 401k so
the problem is it means less money and
so when we bought our home
the mortgage was very very very
comfortable um with his old job and
since he's taking a little bit of a step
back what did he used to make um
about 130. what does he make now
he's gonna make a hundred
and
so you're thinking of backing off the
401k at least for a little bit until you
get settled in
yeah okay i wouldn't do it permanently
but i might do it for six months or even
a year while you get settled into the
new numbers okay the old 401k i would
get with a smart vester pro just click
smartvestor
ramseysolutions.com find someone in your
area that you like and that we endorse
that does stuff the way we teach and you
know the ramsey trusted people right and
so uh
sit down with them and do a rollover on
the old 401k roll it to an ira do not
put it don't if it wasn't in a roth
don't move it to a roth don't make it
taxable but a direct transfer rollover
has no taxes coming out at all so you
want to go ahead and get that set up you
can do that after the first year that's
fine but i wouldn't leave it over the
old company then the second thing is you
start your 401k you're definitely going
to get that six percent going in you may
want to go ahead and go on up to 10 and
then let's see how we're doing from
there as far as your budget goes
i mean
you're guessing and after one month
you'll adjust it and you'll know so just
give yourself plenty of wiggle room but
you've got a big nest you got some money
laying around from the sale of that
house right
so if you miss it a thousand dollars you
just pull some money
one time
right
right but i mean we're not gonna do that
we're not gonna do that every month i
don't wanna subsidize your
your screwed up budget out of your nest
egg and they use up your nest egg but
one month while you're getting
readjusted to the numbers and getting
them dialed in if you need to pull a
little bit of a thousand bucks pull it i
don't care i'm pull three i don't care
if you got a bunch of money laying
around how much you got but that that's
just one thing so you're okay there's no
reason to stress about this and i just
use an 80 figure what's your take-home
pay it's usually 80 it's not gonna be
that far off
um
it may end up being a little bit more a
little bit less depending on what he
claims
and um you know in terms of uh the
dependents and so forth he claims on his
w-4
but you know just start working it and
say okay i'm gonna set it up based on
this if i come up a little bit short i'm
not gonna panic i can either pull some
money or i'll adjust this category over
here after one month you'll have the
numbers
in the second month you'll be able to
just budget on those numbers and that's
what you should do and the good news is
it sounds like you'll be able to so
pretty pretty cool
a lot of folks going through a lot of
turmoil yeah john with um
forced career changes yeah
um by forrest i mean they are um
choosing to i i want to work in a place
that
um
has a different set of values yeah and
uh we're seeing a bunch of
uh i met some folks that joined us last
week here at ramsey and uh the
percentage of them that are ending up
here
because we are in the building together
they they don't want to be working
remote they tried it and it didn't work
for them uh and um you know the whole
vaccine discussion and all that and
people are just freaking out and on all
sides of the equation but some people
only want to work in a place that is
fully vaccinated right
and so it's cool but it's just what it's
doing is causing this tremendous
turnover or
topsy-turviness turbulence in the
employment marketplace
uh that has nothing to do with your
career right
yeah and that's new
it is new and i
i think i actually don't think it's new
i think we felt like it's new i think we
were insulated for a season um but i
think
i think it all distills down to
being comfortable with here's my values
and being comfortable with here's the
things i'll put up with and what i want
and then what am i going to do you know
what am i what can i control in this
situation yeah and good news about them
is they wouldn't control it they
wouldn't control them
it cost them some money which i i i love
that their values were more important
than
x or y and they had put themselves in a
position because they paid off all their
debt that goes back to
that solving for freedom man if you
don't owe anybody any money and then you
get pressed up against a wall with my
values and this is important to me and
my family
man i'm free to shake your hand and
head on down the road yeah and just say
you know bless you yeah i hope that
works for you
i'm gonna go over here and you know you
don't have to be mean or mad about it
everybody's angry yeah yeah i need to be
angry about everything you just be you
and i'll be me it's okay i gotta change
i thought this was gonna be my future
and now it's not and so i'm gonna and
again i'm making it sound light and easy
but the the least amount of that i can i
can
it is a lot lighter and a lot easier
to make a change if you have twenty
thousand or forty thousand dollars in
the bank and no debt absolutely then if
you have twenty or forty thousand
dollars in credit card debt and no money
right it's a different it's a different
thing you leverage yourself on a house
payment and then you can't afford two
car payments and a kid payment my god
now your employer owns you yeah right
yeah the bank owns you yeah yeah there's
something i don't think the borrower's
slave to the lender try this one okay
you got no debt and you walk in the ball
starts yelling and screaming and you
start walking off
and you go where are you going i don't
have any payments look over your
shoulder and go i don't have any
payments and just keep walking and you
know when you say that that way and you
paint that picture in people's mind they
go yeah this borrower is slave thunder
when i don't have any payments i'll make
different choices i wouldn't put up with
that crap yeah and here's what the boss
is gonna do eight times out of ten
they're gonna want to set up a coffee
with you yeah no uh usually when i get
to barking people run away and you you
just smiled at me tell me what tell me
what's going on here
right that's it that's exactly what you
just looked at over as you were walking
out you looked over your shoulder see
you
see you man see you man when you're
doing temperature i'll be here dude you
can have a temper tantrum somewhere else
you freaking four-year-old
it's a different thing man
i want people to own their values
we're in a season now where everybody's
yelling about everybody else's values
yeah how about how about taking care of
you that's your full-time job and you
know what like me and my wife we're not
gonna put us in this
business in the workplace or in the
school great i'm going to own it and
then when you're a kid none yet none
your business i'm owner man
tall tall
there's a
whole sitcom on when i was a little kid
bewitched yeah and the woman that always
looked across the street minding the
other people's business gladys gladys
get away from the window
well here's what they're doing now
the whole stinking culture has gone to
being gladys instead of karen's they're
gladys
this is the ramsey show
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality best-selling author
of the book redefining anxiety is my
co-host today we're here to talk to you
about your money your relationships your
personal mental health
your work whatever it is with your life
the ramsay show is here to help you you
jump in and we will talk about you right
in front of you the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five philadelphia starts off this hour
with gregory hi gregory how are you
hey dave i'm doing good how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so my question is um if me and my
girlfriend should be getting our first
home together within the next year let
me give you a little back story
uh i have a i have a hundred fifty
thousand dollars in student loans uh
it's not the only debt i have
i've been paying that for about
uh a few years now i have a steady job
and uh my girlfriend
um she is just beginning her career in
the military as a
second lieutenant
and she has no student loans
and we've come to the realization that
it is cheaper for us to get to pay a
mortgage
as long as we get it for the right price
and everything you know all that stuff
than it is to pay the rent um so that's
why we've started this kind of
conversation of should we be getting a
home yeah
how old are you guys
uh i'm 25 she's 22.
okay you understand they're going to
move her in two to three years
um we're hopefully not she's she's in
the space force and uh she's in the what
yeah
and the space force the new branch uh
the united states space force i knew it
dave star wars is real
i knew it
okay
all right so she may stay put all right
so um
listen you've thought this through
uh trying to use the best logic you can
with advice from broke people that are
your friends
and so i'm going to give you an answer
that is completely perpendicular to what
you think is the truth so it may be very
very hard for you to actually
uh hear the answer so i'll try to give
you my supporting evidence as well okay
okay
never buy a house
never
buy a house
with someone you're not married to
you wanna know why
because you might end up studying
breaking up is hard to do
it's hard enough to do when you have the
legal document called divorce that
assists you
in pushing through the process but
basically what you have here under what
the under the law is what's called a
general partnership
and let me tell you like in 30 years of
doing what i'm doing i've seen all these
go wrong i'm like a cancer doctor i know
what causes cancer because i see it all
the time
okay so
um
here's a horrible example and this will
never happen with you
guy and his shacked-up girlfriend go and
buy a house together uh four weeks later
she gets killed in a car wreck
guess who he owns a house with now
her mama
and him are now partners in a house
there was no will of course
yeah that's dangerous isn't it
yeah uh she just decides to leave and
you've got the payments or
um
you just you want to leave but both of
you have got the payments and you can't
get rid of each other because you got
the payments
and the market corrects and then you're
stuck in a stupid house and you're stuck
in a bad corner of a bad relationship of
something that went sour please please
please wait you're married to buy a
house it's going to be better for your
relationship it's going to be better for
your wealth building it's going to be
better for your 10-year from now life
so number one if you want to buy a house
you need to get married first i don't
care if you go to the courthouse today
that's fine with me but you need to be
married because the legality is going to
put your butt in a crack son you're
gonna have a problem that's what's
coming okay and it's weird
it's just weird now the second thing is
don't buy a house while you still got
debt so you got to clean up these
student loans what do you make
right now i make about 55 grand
eventually i'll be promoted to where
i'll be making around 100 in about a
couple years good what do you do
i'm an airline pilot
so you have an aviation degree
yeah you figured it out
okay
all right because that's a bit it's an
expensive degree so you've got a 150 000
aviation degree and you're making 55 000
a year on your way to making 100 as you
get your hours in right
uh
once i upgrade to the captain to the
last seat yes yeah cool and that's going
to be based on hours really and a few
certs maybe maybe getting certified on a
certain aircraft or something okay cool
well you got a wonderful career ahead of
you and it's a lot of fun what you're
doing
um
and you'll never be able to keep up with
her because she's in the space thing
you're just playing in the air but um
[Laughter]
but
but
yes i yeah buy a house after you've paid
off this 150 000 in debt and after you
get married now i don't know if i talked
you out of it gregory
but if i didn't
you'll call me back in a few years with
the dadgum mess you made and i'll have
to help you with that and i'll still
help you then because i've made messes
in my life too and i'm not gonna pick on
you but please don't be the mess
there's something about the poverty
mindset which is i gotta get through
today and then maybe i can get through
tomorrow and that's as far as i can see
and that is the conversation somebody
who didn't have any money who's saying
well it'd be cheaper today if we buy a
house because our payment on this thing
is going to be cheaper it's not and
you're not it's not home ownership's
more expensive than rent yes absolutely
period but you're just missing a
long-term view man and that's why
the dadgum roof leaks oh oh you got to
replace the roof the heating air goes
out the stupid water heater goes out you
forget all that stuff when you're doing
all your little calculations about
payments versus rent payments
and you just got well everybody tells
you to because stupid people are all
around you going buy a house buy a house
buy a house buy a house oh god if you
don't buy a house you're going to hell
renters all go to hell you need to buy a
house
it's like a salvation issue or something
oh my god you know so it's just nuts so
that's the problem is everybody you're
wasting your money you're throwing your
money down a rat hole people who never
saw a rat or rat hole talking about
throwing your money down a rat hole and
uh unbelievable so you're not throwing
your money down a rat hall yeah it's
patience you're gonna get a house
when you're dead free and married
and i'd love for you to be both this
year
but it's probably not going to happen
on the debt-free part this year
but if you got married and worked on
that goal together you get there faster
so that's what i would do young man
but again
you're gonna do what you're gonna do um
and but you you know if you call here
you're uh we're obligated to tell you
what we think the truth is
the difference in my suggestion is it's
long all of the outcomes long term are
good
the difference in your suggestion is
most of the outcomes
in your suggestion are bad
there is only one possible outcome that
this works in
only one and even then it slows down
your wealth building
so um yeah it's just please please don't
buy a house of people you're not married
to oh god please don't buy a house with
150 000 in student loan debt this
only ship it won't sail is a partnership
and you're getting ready to have a
general partnership with no partnership
documents
just ask your attorney friend if that's
a good idea
oh
nightmare
this is the ramsey shot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today most people know me as the
guy who did a lot of stupid with zeroes
on the end the get out of debt guy
um because i made a lot of money
and i lost it all in my 20s i got the
opportunity to start again after being
bankrupt
and i started learning god's grandma's
ways of handling money and i started
applying them
basic financial common sense in a series
of steps that we call the baby steps by
following these steps i became a
millionaire again this time i did it the
right way and i spent the next three
decades the last 30 years of my life
guiding millions and millions and
millions and millions of people through
the same plan i followed and the
evidence is now here we have tens of
thousands of people who followed those
baby steps and became millionaires
we call them baby steps millionaires
and we cover all of this in the first
book i have done in eight years i
haven't done a book in a long long time
the last book i did was the number one
bestseller with my daughter rachel cruz
smart money smart kids
this one's called baby steps
millionaires
it comes out january the 11th and it's
all about how to become a millionaire
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can too
everybody's talking about building
wealth right now and this is a this is
the real proven way that it's actually
been done
and
all the stories and the evidence is
there the study that we did a couple of
years back here at ramsey the airtight
research the largest piece of research
ever done on millionaires in north
america over 10 000 of them studied the
the the uh conclusions of that study are
in the back of the book um and so we
talk about that we talk about real baby
steps millionaires how they did it we
talk about the things that people
believe that keep them from getting
there
and uh it's only 20 bucks
if you want to pre-order it you get 100
plus almost 150 worth of bonus items
with a pre-order you'll get the baby
steps millionaire's audiobook read by me
the e-book the legacy journey audio book
read by me and e-book the baby steps
millionaires live stream
uh which is coming up here soon
in january
and uh the ramsey smart tax filing
the online tax filing with federal that
uh completely free and a 30-day trial to
ramsey plus which puts you through all
of the stuff you need to do like
financial peace university every dollar
and all of that so all of that included
for 20 bucks
uh it's unbelievable deal why because we
you know if we pre-sell a bunch of books
it helps us with the marketing it says
simple so baby steps millionaires comes
out january the 11th on sale now at
ramseysolutions.com
for 20 bucks our question of the day is
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code the magic
word ramsey to get the best possible
deal today's question comes from kerry
in texas kerry writes my fiance proposed
to me before we moved across the country
for new jobs we both make over a hundred
grand a year but he has a lot of debt i
don't know how much debt he has because
he hasn't completely shared that with me
yet
i'm debt free with a net worth of 880
000 should we wait until he's debt free
to get married if not should i ask for a
prenuptial agreement due to the
difference in our financial situations
dave i'll let you handle the pre-nut but
i'm gonna tell carrie don't get married
y'all have too many unspoken
conversations y'all need to have there's
some bigger issues going on here man
that's
man that's that's my thought yeah if you
if he won't tell you how much daddy he
has how'd you get
married ever i mean you don't get
married until you got the air cleared on
this
how are you gonna make a human i hear
this all the time dave people will tell
you everything they'll tell you this and
that
they'll make babies how much debt does
he have i don't know he didn't want to
talk about it i got three kids with him
but i don't know yeah i've made a human
with him but i don't know how much money
he owes mastercard that's ridiculous
yeah you don't do that that's true um so
here's the thing
um
john's right
the number one cause of divorce in north
america today is money fights and money
problems
and um so you've got to get on the same
page about money before you get married
whoever you are
whatever the situation is as a matter of
fact i'll carry it a little bit further
all the data tells us also on the
marriage stats
that um the other three things that
break up marriages are kids how many to
have and how to raise them
are the inmates going to run the asylum
or are we going to raise stepford
children
um you know we're overly strict or or we
just have a
craziness in the house all the time
whichever it is
or
do the uh
you know
religion is number three
uh are you in agreement on religion
christians call that unequally yoked but
are you in agreement on religion
uh that breaks up marriages like crazy
and the fourth one that breaks up
marriage marriages like crazy is in-laws
how we gonna handle the crazy people on
the extended part of the family because
there is always some crazy people in the
extended part of the family how we gonna
handle that and if you can have those
four discussions in depth preferably in
the setting of a pre-marriage counselor
money religion
kids and in-laws you get on the same
page on all that in-depth discussions
you have set yourself up for a
statistically
very good chance of a successful
marriage and can i go one step below
that there's talking about those four
issues is really important
creating a
language or an environment
to where not if but when my
my faith journey looks different now
than it did 20 years ago 25 years ago
when i met sheila what i thought i was
going to how was going to raise kids
looks
different than it does actually having
two of them and one of them's really
mean to me dave
it changes right so how are we going to
have these conversations together as we
roll too but i mean what are the what
are the what are the principles the
guiding values right yes
of this are and so
it's just i mean one of you is way over
here that's right and the other one's
way over there on something you're gonna
struggle you really are it's gonna be an
issue so back to your question though um
so number one you guys have got to sit
down and get on the same page you have
to know everything about his money he
has to know everything about your money
including your fears of having a good
net worth while he doesn't
and that's a good that's a good part of
the money discussion
i do not recommend prenups unless the
difference in the wealth is extreme
yours is borderline if you got a million
dollars and he has a negative half
million dollars of net worth because
he's got a million dollars of student
loan debt and no money you know that's
pretty extreme it's a me and a half
swing
um so you may want to consider it at
that point but it the problem people run
the prenups as if
that is going to protect cause their
relationship to work after they didn't
talk about crap they should have talked
about
and so you're hiding think how bunkers
that is for hiding behind the prenup is
what most people are doing but now i
will tell you you know like for instance
if i die my wife is going to be worth
hundreds of millions of dollars
she is now and she would still be and i
would suggest to her that she get a
prenup yeah because she's probably not
going to find her equal if she were to
remarried in uh in wealth and it's
dangerous and it's really not even
dangerous for the person you're marrying
it's all the people that are attached
that are weird
like your crazy uncle comes out of the
uh your his crazy uncle comes out of the
closet once he figures out that
the financial closet once he figures out
that uh
his nephew married a rich girl that's
exactly right and he's gonna show up
over there with all these new ideas
about a pizza parlor he wants to open
you know and that's kind of crazy he's
gonna slip and hurt his knee on your
back patio prenup helps with some of
that because you just look at uncle
crazy pizza and go no i ain't anything
shit's hurt we got a prenup and can't
touch it so it helps with running off
the crazies and managing them because
they do come out of the woodwork the
more difference that there is two broke
people get together and other crazies
care that's right so uh but one of
them's rich somebody one of the craziest
is all interested now you know so um and
that's what i've you know i see this
with like we work with pro athletes you
know or we work with uh
music people around nashville and and
this kind of stuff and we see that
occasionally so there's an occasion for
that when i first started i would just
say no prenups no matter what but i've
seen enough crazy that i i now am okay
with that in an extreme situation so
yeah you may want to end up with a
prenup but it's the last part of this
entire discussion i want you to close
the discussion with that not open the
discussion with that which means that
you got all the other work done
then the prenup is going to be in a good
setting
and it's mainly to keep the other people
out not him but don't start a marriage
moving across the country together when
you won't even talk about how much money
you have we don't even move across the
country together we can't even talk
about money you won't talk about how
scared you are of his situation there's
so much unspoken don't start a marriage
with secrets
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
merry christmas
america we're so glad you're with us
thanks for hanging out dr john daloni
ramsay personality is my co-host today
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five dave is with
us in pensacola florida hi dave how are
you
i'm great how you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
um well i'm currently doing my mba i
started it because uh koben gave us a
bunch of free time but uh i am about
three weeks away from being done or if i
get a specialty uh it can cost an extra
16 weeks and because ta covers a good
amount of it it's only gonna cost about
twelve hundred dollars but i'm trying to
get like from your perspective does that
actually add any credibility because
what i'm trying to do in my next
career field i guess you call it is
trying to help people with their
personal finances
what's the specialty
personal finance uh doge finance
finance okay
okay very little of an mba that i've
ever seen curriculum has personal
finance in it though
it's true i started the
nba is kind of because of the free time
when the ta was going to cover most of
it anyways so i was like all right well
i'm not sure what i want to do now i
might go get it for 1200 just because i
want it
okay but i don't think it'll roi
i i if you make 1200 in your entire life
because you got specialization in
finance versus just mba i'd be shocked
you might
if you got into a real nuanced job of
some kind that was
totally corporate finance driven
but the number of
people that will
you know if you're going into personal
finance is what you mentioned right
it is
okay if you're going into that the
number of people that care whether your
mba is
in finance a specialization in finance
or whether you even have an mba
is close to zero
um i love mbas i've got a bunch of them
working on my team i don't have one i've
got a phd in dumb but um
but uh and it's not cost me it's not
held me back one dollar
in terms of because the number of people
that i've been able to help has not had
anything to do with
um
the credibility that a degree gave me
now knowledge
has given me the ability to help a lot
of people knowledge is a good thing but
the credibility that a degree gave me
i wouldn't fool with it but i think you
like
studying and and
uh you like the academic process
um i kind of hear that in the way you're
asking the question and i so i think you
might ought to do it for you
i'm just wondering is there something
you're you're about to graduate and is
there something you feel like you don't
know that you need 16 more weeks in
school to learn because let me say this
twelve hundred dollars for a certificate
in mba programs that's not a lot of
money that's a deal i would take that
all day but it's the 16
16 what weeks or months of your life
you're gonna have to devote back to this
thing so what are you missing here
um not really anything uh
you're right like i like doing the
studying thing but i'd be good to be
done for a little bit i started it
basically because i finished flight
school and kind of missed the academic
portion of it um and so
the only thing i was kind of thinking of
is if i was going into finance and i was
this close to getting something that
said finance on the degree anyways
because my bachelor's in accounting but
if no one's going to care then it might
not have nobody can be worth the squeeze
nobody cares 99 of the jobs don't care
and uh 99.99 percent of people don't
care
all they care about is do you care
and can you help them are you a good
coach and you know what you're talking
about that's what they care about do you
care and can you help them
and so
the number of times someone has said
dave you have a bass you you have a
bachelor's in in finance which is mine's
in finance with specialization in real
estate my ba but you know you have a
you know you have a bachelor's you have
an undergrad is all and so you're not
qualified to get me out of debt
in 30 years i've never heard that one
time now i've heard a lot of people call
me stupid
but i've never never one time i heard
somebody go oh you're not you don't have
enough degrees to help me get out of
debt you know you don't have enough
degrees to help me put my budget
together or run the calculation on my
mutual fund
you're not qualified i've never heard
that it just doesn't come up uh but they
do care that i
you know have some life experience
that's valuable and that i actually know
the answer to the question right
regardless of where i got the answer so
that's that's what matters especially in
this field when it comes down to that to
that coaching man know what you're
talking about and then be able to
communicate it a big part of leadership
and coaching is being able to be heard
right can you speak and be heard and
man yeah you know i
truthfully what would be more useful
but it's probably not available in this
situation
is if you can pick up uh if you want to
go back and study six or eight weeks i'd
go pick up some grad level psych classes
pick up a counseling class had a listen
yeah
yeah
i'd i'd go
if you want to spend 1200 go spend it in
the psych section yeah uh psychology
section and a counseling class uh
i took a class a thousand years ago when
i was in college while i was in getting
my undergrad i took a bunch of graduate
level stuff just because i was
interested yeah not because i actually
used them as
credits in my undergrad but they were
just they were graduate level stuff like
i took one called motivation and emotion
that was
you know in depth detail
uh
psychology nerd stuff and i loved it i
had a black but i just learned i like
wondering how people tick yeah what
makes them do what they do and so
um
you know that's uh
that but i think that's probably more
valuable if you're going to be working
in personal finances to know the
personal part too and this brings up a
good question dave we often talk about
the cost of higher ed the cost of some
of these programs being the what you put
out
for tuition
and in this case like we said 200 bucks
for a certificate mba program is nothing
nothing
but we forget if you go to school for
four years and you pay a hundred grand
or 150 grand you also have four years of
not working
right 16 weeks yeah that's the
opportunity cost on the time right or
the four more months you're not going to
be working full time or you could be
making another money doing some other
stuff and so that that 16 weeks has a
cost to it as well and i don't know what
that is in your life if you're single
and you're just working a full-time job
and doing this at night maybe nothing um
or maybe you're putting a full-time job
down the road a little bit
that's an interesting discussion
all right kelly's in seattle hi kelly
how are you
i'm wonderful thank you so much sure
what's up
so um my husband and i have worked the
baby steps um read all your books um
and
we um
we paid we paid off our mortgage
i had um talked with you a while ago we
sold
a
rental house um
and that kind of got us um
got us to be able to pay off the
mortgage so we we did about 75 000 just
on our own and then we sold that
um
yeah and it's amazing so we have another
house
that was our starter home that we um we
still rent out and our mortgage on that
is a hundred and twenty two thousand
dollars
and we have
two um we have a hundred and twenty
thousand left left over from the
sell of the the other rental house
that's you don't that's an addition to
your emergency fund
in addition to our yep we have our our
emergency fund is done great um wow
yeah and my husband uh we have the
blessing of all in this this trifecta
his work started offering a
roth 401k with a match
so we're putting
23 percent
we sat down and we maxed that out so
we're doing that now
um
so
part of the the drive for paying off our
debt is our house
needs some some love
and
we're kind of on the fence if we take
the 120 and pay off the other rental and
own it outright
or if we
split it and use
about 60 000 to
get some stuff done on our current home
that we live in and own now what's your
household income
a hundred and ten thousand
okay i i can tell you what david sharon
ramsey would do and we would never look
back
i pay off that rental instantly when you
get off the phone
and then i would i would i would back my
retirement down to 15 not 23
and i'd start saving aggressively to do
the remodel in phases
three twenty thousand dollar phases and
i'd start the other phase and meet the
first phase immediately
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today merry christmas america
we're so glad you're here open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five robin is with us in montana hi
robin welcome to the ramsey show
hey thank you so much thank you very
much for taking my call this is really
great to talk with you you too what's up
um so my husband and i follow your baby
steps and my husband recently retired as
a wildland firefighter in forest service
and he brought back all of his military
time with the army wow and he kept
money in his tsp using the same
allocations that you recommend the 80 c
20 s and 20 high
and now he can no longer contribute to
his tsp and we won't be touching that
money for about seven years
and his tsp has been dropping a bit and
he's kind of freaking out a little bit
about it
about what to do with his tsp since that
money is dropping and so he's wondering
should he keep that same allocation
or this is where we kind of disagree or
move it to the g fund until the market
recovers since he can't buy any of the
stock while it's you know kind of on
sale when it's down
and so he feels like he might be taking
you know he but he'll be taking a loss
with little to gain from it and
and he'll listen to and follow whatever
you say but he's just worried about
losing it all and not being able to buy
it back later
i never
never
recommend timing the market
when you move when you move money out of
the market when it's down you lock in
guarantee
your losses
in the name of safety
and it's a false
indicator of safety it's not real safety
um and so i would never
tell him to move it to the g
what i would do
is say why don't we roll the whole
stinking thing into a traditional ira
which you can do
and
put it in mutual funds that you like
with long track records that'll
outperform the mix in the tsp
with a good smartvestor pro that's what
i would do i always recommend
with very very rare exceptions
99 of the time that when you leave a
company you take your retirement with
you and roll it to a traditional ira
there's no taxes when you do that you
have much better options in the open
market than your limited options in your
old retirement plan
and you can spread it across and pick
mutual funds
that are
performing if you're 80 c
and it's down it means the market's down
okay and the c is a common stock
index it works like the s p 500 the s p
500 is the 500 most represented stocks
on the stock market
and so it is the stock market the s p
500 index is the stock market and if the
c is 80 of your portfolio and your
portfolio is going down
that means the stock market's going down
and meaning there's no place to hide
you're going to ride the wave you're
going to ride the roller coaster up and
down and you've got plenty of time
there's nothing to panic about
he's just feeling weird because he's not
adding to it to offset any losses and uh
but i you know i've got plenty of money
that in my own that is up and down
whatever the market's doing because it's
in my retirement and it's in good mutual
funds and it just rides the wave so what
i would do is meet with the smartvestor
pro learn
some historical data about the market
and go okay here's what the market's
been doing here's why your sea was
driving this down
what was dry or what was driving the tsp
down
and uh and here's some mutual funds and
here's what they will do when this
market is going down which likely they
will go down too by the way
um if the market's going down the
market's just going down that's part of
it and you ride the market down you
write it up it's the roller coaster ride
nobody gets hurt on a roller coaster
except those that jump off in the middle
so uh write it baby write it what is a
tsp thrift savings plan federal
government and military okay
if you're a federal government employee
uh and you have options in the thrift
savings plan
the c plan each of those represent a
different segment of our type of
investing the g is a guarantee okay so
it's a very low return
uh like putting your money in the money
market or something okay okay or putting
it in bonds or something low rate of
return but low risk does it not very
volatile but you're gonna make nothing
and you've moved
like let's say you're let's say you had
a hundred thousand dollars and it went
down so it's worth eighty thousand
dollars and you move it into g
a hundred percent of the time it's not
coming back that's exactly right you
just locked you locked in your losses
you lost that twenty thousand dollars
where if you had a hundred and became
eighty it's going to go back up to 100
right if you leave it alone and let it
ride the wave right
and so that's what historical data
and understanding that will cause you to
be able to keep your stinking hands off
of it not try to time the market right
and timing the market is all about greed
or fear
it's never about data right no data
tells us to time the market but if i'm
afraid i'll jump out or if i'm greedy
i'll jump in
and um that's jumping in and out and
there's like i don't know i've probably
read 25 studies over my life
uh some of them more credible than
others but they all come to the same
conclusion that market timers do not
keep up with people who buy and hold
never never never yeah like never i've
never
never seen a single piece of research
that indicates jumping in and out beats
but we all have this thing that you want
to tell your golfing buddy that you
caught you know you hit this
you hit this uh within two inches of the
pin or i caught a catfish at seventy
three thousand pounds or i killed a 73
point buck or what i mean we've all got
these dead gum moby dick things out
there that we're gonna the white whale
that we're gonna get and it's just not
there and uh but everybody wants to do
it they bought that stock that one time
and it went up and then they jumped out
at just the right time and the answer to
all that is bull crap it didn't happen
that's right it's just like your fishing
buddy your golfing buddy it didn't
happen the very first job i had that had
a any type of retirement to it i
remember talking to some guys who were
actual traders and i was asking some i
mentioned something about the wall
street journal this is
20 years ago
and the guy looked at me and said
if it's in the wall street journal and i
don't know about it
then i'm not doing my job and i remember
thinking oh so by the time it gets to me
distilled through the wall street
journal down to some local
i'm so far behind any decision i'm
making yeah and i just remember going
you're not hours behind your days days
behind us oh and especially these days
man it's so everything's so fast
i can't write that when guys come and
come to work in a car longer than your
house and their only job is to study the
auto industry and yet you picked an auto
stock that beat them exactly or now
their job is to manage the ai computers
that are trading these
you're not going to win just put in
there and let it sit man yeah you ride
the wave if you believe in the economy
if you believe in the american business
or even foreign business if you're in a
foreign fund if you believe in business
to make a profit and give you a return
on investment and you believe that based
on the data that shows you over the past
25 years in the past 30 years over the
past five years here's what this has
done
then that's what the bet is and it's
just like buying a house in a good
neighborhood you go okay
everybody knows what's a good
neighborhood it's good ever is stable
it's not got cars up on blocks in the
front yard you know they're not
they do know what a weed eater is you
know and you know this and consequently
the homes are well kept maintained and
guess what the
good people live there is not a bunch of
crime it goes up in value this is what
we call a good neighborhood it's a
predictable environment to invest your
housing dollar
all your neighbors thought that until
dave ramsey moved in
there went the neighborhood
there went the neighborhood they said ah
we researched it and everything well it
is on a golf course and now all now they
got broken windows yeah but yeah but i
mean
but yeah it's uh um
man yeah it's it's
that's the thing is
you you when you buy a piece of real
estate if you know the area like i grew
up in nashville so i can just i just
know what's happening there because just
because i'm hanging out you know i don't
even have to do a bunch of
formal research but i've just
anecdotally kind of know here's what's
happening in this area and oh my gosh
did you hear about that and then you
could go you can do a little bit of
research and add to the historical data
but you kind of know if i buy in there
and i hold it
i'm going to be okay right
and that's what you do with mutual funds
you're buying a good neighborhood if i
buy in there
and i hold it
i'm going to be okay
and this is the formula that
millionaires use
day traders people who buy and sell that
are
think they're robin hood
wink wink they're doing game stop and
all that bullcrap
78 percent of the day traders lose money
this is not a formula for wealth
building
[Music]
when 78 of people doing anything lose
money and you do it what do you think
you are the exception
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit the theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your relationships
yourself
your work
your money your mental health all of it
right here on the ramsey show the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five brock is in lincoln
nebraska hi brock welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave and john thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
so i'm 20 years old i'm recently engaged
congratulations beyonce
thank you
me and my fiancee are both blessed to
have parents who taught us
financial
uh wisdom
and we both obviously save and budget
separately since we're not quite married
yet um but my question is uh we both
have um a pretty good chunk in our
savings my mine's been mostly mutual
funds uh hers is just in a savings
account way to go we want to buy a house
right
we want to buy a house before
we get married but we don't know how to
do that because our our finances aren't
combined yet we don't know if you would
recommend doing that a month before
we're married or a week or after the
wedding
um so that's kind of my question today
okay
um
well you're probably not going to like
my answer
if i woke up in your shoes knowing what
i know as an old guy
i'm going to tell you to be married a
year
before you close on the house okay
after you're married a year you will
pick a different house than you will
out of the honeymoon
because you know each other better
uh the joke we always use is it takes
about a year to know how close to your
mother-in-law to buy
but it's kind of that's kind of you know
we all laugh about that because it takes
a little while to get to know some
things that we think we know prior to
actually living together
uh and being married together and all
that stuff but we really don't know and
you've got plenty of time you're very
wise with your money you can use that
year to pile up money and to study the
real estate market together to dream
together to talk about things together
the things you want in a house the
things you don't care about in a house
that uh whether you want land or you
don't want land uh you know nebraska
right that kind of stuff and so
um you know just just give yourself a
little time here don't be in such a
hurry uh and that one year is going to
cause you to make a much wiser
decision
and um there's a rule in the old
testament
that uh
like for instance under king david when
the uh armies of israel would go to
battle
a man and woman get married the first
year they were married they didn't allow
the men to go to battle
and uh because because they wanted them
to get their marriage set to get knit
because they made a better warrior
than
that right and uh this is kind of in
that same vein yeah no i i could not
agree more take your time man you've got
the rest y'all are so smart and so ahead
of the game
um i'd love y'all to spend a year just
enjoying figuring out what y'all just
did and how y'all gonna do the rest of
your life together man
yeah and it's just yeah
curtain right hanging curtains can cause
a divorce
and so don't do that just don't do that
in the first two weeks of marriage you
know it's like
if if you guys have time i have one more
question for you you got it
so uh i have about 1500 in a 401k
through my employer um and i actually
just recently talked to smart investor
crow and they recommended not
getting involved in a roth uh ira quite
yet uh but i didn't know if you would
spend any differently um
yeah well and that's that's kind of what
i was wondering why why did they say
that
well he said just to dump all of my
money into savings for a home okay but
if you're recommending if you're
recommending that i buy a year from now
i figured i could same thing though
you'd have a big old savings for a home
here's the good news okay if you run the
numbers
starting your retirement plan when
you're 21 instead of when you're 20
you're still very rich
[Laughter]
so you're going to be just fine you got
you know and you still get a house
you're very very rich because you
started so stinking early and if you get
a house and all the 40 year olds said
yes that you both like oh man you're
going to be rich both relationally and
financially man yeah you know just take
your time
move through this steady slow and steady
wins the race slow and steady wins the
race just keep a rhythm and you've got
such a really wise
start on this so just very very very
well done
good question sir congratulations on the
engagement
tom is with us in grand rapids michigan
hey tom welcome to the ramsey show
ah what a pleasure dave
yeah um
something happened today
my wife uh just got a check
an inheritance
and some is in a uh
if uh beneficiary ira and the rest is in
a uh inheritance but she just got a lump
sum check today
and um
we put it in the bank but we need to
have some guidance how much
uh 160. wow
nice who passed away
well her aunt and uncle oh my goodness
the proverbial rich uncle
we've all heard about him you actually
had one yeah
she's uh
yeah
i'm sad but it happened uh well almost
uh over a year ago oh okay wow well
here's the thing gosh that's wonderful
um sorry that he passed but it's
wonderful you guys got an inheritance we
would use it on wherever you guys are in
the baby steps have you ever heard of
the baby steps
yes yes i've listened to you for
so do you have any debt a long time
uh we owe um
68 on our home
not today
you're debt-free today you're debt-free
today brother okay any other dad
excuse me you got any other debt
uh
no
good okay so i pay off my house today
that puts you in baby step seven the
rest of the money there are three things
you should always do with money and you
should always label any money that comes
in give it a name give it a label a
mission okay and it needs to fall in one
of these three categories and i always
recommend trying to do a little bit of
all three categories you need to enjoy
some of it that's splurge or lifestyle
or whatever you want to call it
number two you need to invest some of it
and number three you need to be generous
with some of it and i suspect that if
you reasonably enjoyed some of the money
your house was debt free
and uh you reasonably were generous with
someone and you reasonably invested some
of it that her uncle would be smiling
from heaven saying i'm sure left glad i
left that smart win some money yeah how
cool is that i'm just thinking if i was
an uncle and i passed away and the money
that i had saved to steward was i gave
it to one of my nieces or nephews
and they steward it by paying off their
debt and being able to give oh my gosh
man that's it why have legacy if not for
that right yeah
anytime you get an inheritance if you
kind of most of the time i mean it
depends on who left it but most of the
time you think about what would make
that person smile
generally that's going to lead you
towards wisdom yeah
congratulations is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 dollars a year go
to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
so
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
you know you can't turn on your
television your radio open your news
feed without hearing the latest and
greatest plan to get rich quick
crypto nothing down real estate single
stocks
nfts everybody's talking about an easy
way to get rich
well i got great news for those of you
that want to build wealth we have a huge
event on thursday january the 13th
called
building wealth
2022
rachel cruz george campbell and i are
going to make sense of all the get rich
quick noise out there and show you how
to really
build real
wealth in 2022.
we've already sold out of in-person
tickets over a thousand folks are coming
and uh we're offering a free live stream
and if you don't want to miss out on the
free live stream we would suggest you
register to get signed up for it
ramseysolutions.com
and register for a free live stream of
our building wealth event
coming january the 13th
stu is with us in kansas city hi stu
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure i'll try to get right to the point
um
i have a simple ira through my company
and traditionally it's been a three
percent match so i put three percent in
that account
um i have an emergency fund i have a
small family with a hundred and twenty
thousand dollar salary my wife stays at
home with our children
um i've only been putting three percent
into that simple ira
because i've been in the background
saving for a down payment on a home and
i've about achieved that by say april or
may of this year cool my question for
you is thank you my question is
i want to now
bump my investments up to 15 or more of
my take home but the real question is my
company has grown and we're now
switching to a 401k
instead of this this simple ira and the
match has also changed so instead of
three for three it's you put in six you
get three
so my question for you is dave
do i put in
that six percent and if i do should i do
it pre-tax or roth and then
where do i go and what's your best
recommendation on the other
percentages to get to 15 or 20. great
questions in this situation and please
ask for more details great question
you've really really outlined your
situation beautifully thank you you've
really thought through this thank you
sir okay here's the rule and then let me
tell you how the root why the rule works
and so you'll know what to do on your
own without me that's the whole idea
here um
rock paper scissors
match
beats roth
beats traditional
okay
in other words so the way we would fill
out your plan is we're going to do as
much match as we can so we're going to
do your six percent
the match by the way is always in
traditional but you can do a roth 401k
but the portion they give you to match
is always in the traditional side and
you have to move it over to the roth
ever so often if you want to and pay the
taxes on it at that point but match okay
beats roth beats traditional so we would
do your six percent and then if that's a
roth 401k
at the the new one they've got then i
would uh
you know i would select rother for your
401k for your match and if you want to
just keep going in there until you get
to 15 that's fine if you can't get to 15
in the 401k or if your 401k only has
traditional available
match beats rothbeach traditional so we
would go to do an individual roth
for six thousand bucks
and uh before in good mutual funds
before we did traditional now why does
match beat roth and why does roth beat
traditional that's the question i will i
just want to ask you they the the
company plan
offered both traditional and raw good
you want to match to both you want rob
okay but their match portion by law has
to be in
the in traditional they cannot match you
in the wrath meaning you can put in
you can put in roth but the portion they
give you they has not had taxes paid on
it and will grow taxable
the portion that they give you okay so
the reason match beats roth is roth
throws tax free
at the rate of the mutual fund
okay so let's say your mutual fund does
10
and that's tax-free right
match yes i just told you it's going
gonna be taxable
but it's a hundred percent
because you put in
two thousand bucks and they put in or
you put in six percent and they matched
it they gave you free money so free
money even after you pay the taxes on it
is more
than just tax-free does that make sense
yes sir so the match is you always want
to get all the match you can get before
you do anything else once you've gotten
the match then tax-free
broth beats traditional here's why let's
say we're putting in 100 a month from
age 25 to age 65 and it grows to a
million dollars which is about what it
would do
okay
and so if you got a million dollars in a
roth there's zero taxes on it
you got a million dollars in traditional
same hundred bucks a month same mutual
funds grew the same exact amount
one of them's taxable one of them's not
she got a million dollars in a roth or
you got a million dollars in traditional
the million dollars in the roth has zero
taxes the million dollars in the
traditional is taxed so 250 000 of it's
going to taxes
okay so after taxes your traditional 75
cents on the dollar
and your roth is 100 cents on the dollar
and your match is 120 cents on the
dollar
okay match beats roth
beats traditional so you want to do all
the match you can do then all the roth
you can do
and then if you still hadn't gotten to
15 then you would do some traditional
and only then
but there's no traditional that beats
roth and you would just dump that in the
traditional that they had to open for
the match
yeah you just put it in that same
account yeah okay you just you open a
roth 401k
they give you match that match portion
is has to be taxable gotcha by law now
now what i do here for those of you
there in baby step seven and that kind
of thing
is um
i it's weird i own the company so i
match myself it's just stupid nice of
you yeah it's sweet of me i like me but
the um so i've got a real good benefits
plan for me
it's all about me but yeah
brother yeah i'm an employee technically
so i
match myself but i i
and i have to do the same thing and then
once a year right now as a matter of
fact i notify the broker that manages
our 401k and they move i can roll that
matching portion from traditional into
roth which makes it taxable so i have to
pay taxes on that amount of money then
but from this point forward it gross
tax-free gotcha
and uh at 61 it's starting to be
questionable whether i need to do that
or not except i will never touch that
money so it will be left to the
beneficiaries it wouldn't be left to me
because i'll never use that money i
don't need any of that money because
i've got other money but
if you're going to need the money
it starts to be questionable in your
late 60s whether you do roth or
traditional but past that
past year late before your late 60s it's
all roth all roth tax free growth
uh khalif is with us khalif is in durham
north carolina hi khalif how are you
hey babe i'm doing good how do you think
better than i deserve right quick what's
your question
yes sir so i went from uh taking a
semester off of school
and working a nine to five that was
really only giving me like eleven
eleven dollars per hour and like 11
hours a week
to getting two jobs uh both paying
around twenty dollars an hour
um i'm trying to decide if i am able to
take both because one has an hour
commute i don't know if that's the smart
thing to do no i do know that
okay
not worth your time it's two hours a day
yeah
you're losing you're losing more money
and you're making and you're burning gas
and tearing up your car
do something else yeah
yeah you need something closing if it's
a part-time job man it's not a career
choice
you know
you're trying to net money when the
smoke clears
yeah do you you love this job
the two jobs that i got that's my old
job that i was talking about the two
jobs that i got are both giving me
twenty dollars an hour and they're both
paying forty dollars
a week regardless
the one is twenty dollars an hour and
the one that's close to me is twenty
dollars an hour forty hours a week and
then the one that's an hour drive is
twenty six dollars an hour
and 40 hours a week so you have 80 hours
a week booked
yes pretty much you are working man well
if you're getting especially if you can
lump up some of those hours and not have
i wouldn't drive an hour
and then work two hours and then drive
an hour back that's not gonna make sense
but if you're gonna get in full lengths
of time maybe i'll maybe i would
withdraw my answer and say yeah do it
you are working like a crazy man get
after it
[Music]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free
stage joe and heidi are with us hey guys
how are you
we're doing great thank you thanks for
having us absolutely where do you guys
live uh fostoria ohio uh it's about 30
miles south of toledo oh wow okay cool
well a pleasure to have you
with some folks from bowling green down
the other day very close right there by
you yeah very cool hey good to have you
guys how much debt have you paid off 121
thousand nine hundred and forty eight
dollars and we also
cash flowed ninety thousand dollars
um during that time during the journey
wow and you're how long did this take uh
four years and ten months okay and um
what was your range of income during
this time uh we started out at 139 and
dropped to 112 000. okay what do y'all
do for a living
oh i am a
call center
operator for a hospital
and i'm a registered nurse i'm a nurse
manager at an assisted living okay wow
very cool i bet you both see and hear a
lot of things huh oh yes yes wow
yes been through a lot the last couple
years really interesting yes very yeah
so what kind of debt was this 122 000
bucks um so there was credit cards um
medical bills uh truck
or equity loan the home equity loan
um home equity loan was the the bigger
piece of it and then the rest was our
mortgage oh you paid off your house
what's the house worth
around 175 000. all right
very nice and it's all yours it is
no matter what happens it's yours
wow way to go guys okay what started
this journey four years and 10 months
ago
well
it kind of started about 10 years ago i
had listened to you on the the radio
and i had bought your book i took it
home um told joe about it and he was
like yeah okay i'll read it later come
on joe i know we could
coffee table it's a great coaster right
exactly
so then um when we got started i saw i
saw the book sitting on the table i'm
like well that's that's interesting i
don't even remember her bringing this
out too six years yeah right
so i i looked interesting i i picked it
up i started reading it i finished it
and i like
you know it was the okay we got to get
our act together and get in gear because
our kids are going to be graduating high
school going to college
and
whatever else
coming our way so we should probably
prepare
we needed to get going wow very cool so
it's just a wake-up call and you just
looking around going we're not doing as
good as we ought to be doing and oh
here's a way to do it exactly that's
simple so the total money makeover book
was it yeah yeah and it was a huge
blessing because um shortly after we
started the journey the reason that our
income went down is that joe got
downsized
so yeah
so it was a huge blessing that i like
being downsized better than right side
right size implies it was wrong that i
was here
you know
down is like you move down after me
that's i like that better it's just
better terminology oh my god who had the
conversation with who who sat down and
said hey
i i was gentle about this book for five
or six years
it's time to get after it
i think it was just me you know after
reading the book saying okay we got to
do this he's finally bored okay it's
about time that's playing the long game
heidi way to go yeah
yeah very cool
so you sat down started doing the budget
started working the stuff and heidi's
been listening to the show anyway so she
knew how to do this stuff yep i was
keeping a budget all along but it was
hard to do by myself so yeah i just
waited you know until he came around
she's patient
totally not patient
good good midwesterner she's kind of
sweet right yeah
hillabilly woman would have hit you with
something
yeah but she'll hide your body and they
will never find it
yeah she's still just grinning
oh my gosh very cool well what do y'all
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is you did it house and everything
man yeah just uh work the baby steps
it's it's not rocket science but it
takes the discipline to just keep
plugging away at the debt and just keep
moving forward
you might slide off the trail a little
bit here and there but get right back on
as soon as you can and and just keep
attacking it what was the 90 000 you
cash flowed in addition to the 122. so
we
paid
part of our kids college
um we had more vehicle repairs that
needed to be done
our daughter got married
and we went on vacation so as soon as we
got rid of our non-mortgage debt we went
on vacation
and then the rest of it was
we actually got the kids
as they graduated high school to go to
because they stayed at local schools
commuted back and forth so we got them
a new used vehicle um
as to help them out okay so you did the
normal like we're gonna be intentional
but not wasteful right while we're on
baby steps four five six mm-hmm and then
you go ahead and knock the house out
while you're doing all that stuff
over a five-year period of time
basically exactly so very very good well
done guys thank you thank you well done
proud of you very very cool your heroes
how does it feel to be free house and
everything feels awesome
it's not it's surreal still yeah we um
um recently went on vacation it's like
let's let's spend a house payment while
we're on vacation and it was just it was
just fun not caring like how much we
spent like we went over we did a good
job spending it but we spent a house
mortgage when we went on a met
[Laughter]
very good that's good i like this joe's
back i like that that's good
and how long have you guys been married
over 25 years have you ever been
debt-free while you're married
i don't think so probably not no will
you ever go back
no no no absolutely no
no and um you know getting started late
in the game my advice is you know
start early as soon as you can and
that's why we got our kids involved our
youngest is here with us today he's
19.
we actually brought our other son and
his fiance with us but
something came up
today where
uh he was having lots of of pain in his
stomach and was like well better be on
the safe side and take you to the
emergency room find you know found out
that he's got um
appendicitis oh my gosh yeah yeah
exactly
appendectomy here in nashville he did
yes he just got out of surgery like a
half hour ago he got out of surgery but
the debt-free screaming
yes my kids are in the hospital having
surgery but i'm here doing my dad's
priorities we asked him
oh my goodness and the fiance is sitting
over there
yeah yeah
thinking that our in-laws are nuts right
over here
yeah they totally understand because we
made them we actually held a fpu class
and opened it up for our church which
all of our kids go to
so our daughter and her soon-to-be
husband um our son and his soon-to-be
wife um all took the class so
once they were done and this was all
before covet hit um our daughter and her
now husband have paid off forty six
thousand dollars in her in her um
tuition
and they did that in 14 months and then
um brian the one that had to have the
surgery him and his fiance been saving
like crazy um they cash flowed their
college um they have enough for a down
payment on a house and they're paying
for most of their wedding and a
honeymoon and they are set to go there
he just paid to have an organ taken i
know right right
and then murphy shows up and says hey
i'm going to take your opponent
this is legacy change and you've changed
your family congratulations
i mean you didn't just get out of that
you changed everything every yeah that's
amazing what an incredible story
wow well we've got a copy of the new
baby steps millionaires book for you
that's the next chapter in your story
thank you you're on your way and a copy
of total money makeover for you to give
away someone can sit it on their coffee
table for six years then it will bloom
it will bloom after six years
and uh it's it's predictable so well
done you guys i'm very very proud of you
and get over there and check out yours
that's where we're going
brian and justin from ohio 122 000 paid
off in four years and 10 months making
137 to 112. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three
two one we're debt-free
and
that's dedication
and just a few minutes ago their son
woke up and said i'm appendix oh
easy sorry you did that you had to do
that was too easy
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 29 25 it is
dangerous to be concerned with what
others think of you
but if you trust the lord you are safe
eleanor roosevelt said you wouldn't
worry so much about what others think of
you if you realize how seldom they do
that's fantastic there we go
boom
greg's in portland oregon hi greg
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dude i'm happy to be here i wish i
was here under better circumstances
and
giving them my debt free speech but uh
not quite there yet
how can we help
well um yeah so i actually live in a
little town outside of portland here in
oregon on the north coast and uh i
married my wife she's she's the sweetest
woman you ever met uh you know about six
years ago
and i lost my job about three months or
so before she moved to the us from out
of state or out of country
um i started my business with the last
350 dollars in my bank account and you
were third for for a while i'll tell you
i'm i'm 26 now i've been doing it for
about five and a half years
and uh it's grown a lot this last year
i've done about 26 growth i'm just now
starting to get a good wage from it uh
my wife's a teacher at the local school
district and she said you know she's
always looking for jobs and she saw an
i.t job there which is basically what i
do now but it's entry level it's
a little bit of a pay cut but it comes
with the benefits and the security of it
and that's what she wants is the
security and she's kind of given me an
ultimatum of you know she doesn't want
to have to deal with the business
anymore the you know up and down of it
and uh said you know
remember i might not be here tomorrow
i just need some fatherly advice here
your wife says she's going to leave if
you don't take a job that is a pay cut
she said she might and it's one of those
where i just don't know you know i
either
call her bluff or she's she's flush you
know
this has nothing to do with this job man
there's there's bigger things going on
your relationship here man
what about your what about your world
makes her feel not safe
why would she even need to make this
statement
well you know i guess i think no i don't
guess you know you know don't guess you
know why doesn't you feel safe why would
she say something like that
you know some months i'm
way above what i would be making there
like three four times and then some
months i'm just under what i'd be making
there yeah but you're talking about
dollars and cents who are you are you
hard to be around in the low months
no no i don't drink you know i don't do
drugs i'm a pretty easy e-going person
you know i
if i'm low then you know i do everything
i can to change it uh i consider it you
know to some extent reflection on myself
and i do everything to better the
situation you know okay uh i don't like
to be mopey if anything i like to just
go to work and double down even more
and you know triple down on things
did i hear you say before you were
married she was an immigrant that she
came from another country
she did yeah she moved to the us here uh
china
china
and so she is an american chinese or
she's chinese
she's chinese and nationality and
uh in an upbringing yes uh her family is
the best people in the world they give
you know her father remember that she's
sweet but also heard her say she's gonna
leave her husband if he didn't get a job
she wanted didn't sound too sweet to me
yeah so i'm not buying the sweet crap
um
something else is going on here man i
don't like it at all i don't know what
just how you just mapped out the way you
handle challenges ups and downs puts you
in the top two percent of men i will
talk to all year that's incredible um so
there's something else going on here um
i don't i don't like dave i don't like
to get in the bluff calling game but i
would flip the lights on here and say
we're gonna go talk to a marriage
counselor today or tomorrow yeah um
because there's there's something bigger
than just the financial sense security
here
yeah because you're making the money
right i interviewed yeah you know i am
and it's kind of funny that's where i'm
seeing
uh you know what right now i'm making
about
34 35 000 a year what does that mean
about 26 percent
and she knew i heard 26 percent i had a
guy tell me it was up 26 percent that
made a dollar too so 22
nothing unless there's some money on the
other end of that formula 56 of zero
still zero
but uh but you're making you know you're
making 38 000 and she's making what
she's making about 42 i make about 35
36.
and i'm seeing the competition crumble
around me you know the only other store
here with staples there's
uh it just went out of business there's
one guy in the uh the next town over
that does it it kind of does it as a
hobby and i'm starting to get clients
from him saying that they're unhappy
i don't ever want to knock somebody in
this is not about your business this is
not about your business my brother
yeah it's about your marriage
that's why i say this isn't going to be
solved with a calculator it's going to
be solved with a marriage counselor
yeah and this sucker's on life support
do you believe her she's threatening you
do you believe her
i don't know you know she's told me
before that she wasn't super happy here
and she was wondering if i was open to
moving to china and i guess at some
extent i was but
you know right now it's just not a place
not a move i want to make you know i
don't have a degree
and uh you know i built this because i
didn't see any other options for work in
my field in the area uh you know
and uh
yeah that's exactly right brother i'm pr
it sounds like you're a hard worker you
stuck around longer than i would have
but it sounds like you're a grinder and
you're a hard worker and you sound like
a guy a character and you sound like a
guy who controls his emotions well and
it sounds like you're married to someone
who is looking for a way to get out
yeah and i hate to be the guy that's
breaking that to you in that way
man no no i you know i need to have
somebody
you know with some experience here just
tell me how it is you know really so
what you want to do in a situation where
we don't know we're we've been on the
radio with you for two minutes and so
it's a long yeah that's a fur piece from
us knowing everything about what's going
on over there but you have cultural
differences
that are pretty extreme
security uh is a different thing when
you come out of a communist background
um
and so and it has a different set of uh
emotions tied to it
but we've also got this uh
unhappiness this wanting to return to
china
uh and maybe this is uh you know you
didn't do it so she had a felt like that
gave her the release i don't know that's
kind of what we're what we're
hypothesizing but the only way to find
out is to here's what you don't want to
do you don't want to just call the bluff
and then wonder what happened
you do want to
enter into this with some good
counseling
and so get on the phone and find a good
christian counselor in your area find a
good pastor in your area that can walk
you guys through this and sit down with
you and find out what the what is really
going on because this is not about you
taking a pay cut
for her to be happy
it's kind of ridiculous when you say it
out loud actually even if you're in
even if your income's volatile now if
she perceives because you don't bring
any money home you pull out it all back
into the business but if you had a
regular job you'd bring some money home
see that's not a pay cut in her mind
then that's a huge increase if you're
not bringing any money into the
household those types of things could
come out in a good counseling session
but i'm with john there's a lot going on
here that leads up to this this is not
sudden
this has been coming on it's been a slow
burn for a while and so you need to get
in what you don't want to have is regret
that you didn't try everything that's
right
so you try everything you flip the
lights on as john said you start
screaming you know fire fire fire and we
run out of the building because there's
a fire well it turns out there's not a
fire but we did at least we didn't die
so we try everything you go to the
counselor and do the best you can and
then when you get down to it she still
takes off and you still don't know why
um but at least you tried everything
yeah and you don't have that regret of
of just kind of
being uh
laissez-faire about your marriage just
whatever you know quesara right now
instead we we give it every shot we got
you leave it all on the field
and then if you lose you left it all in
the field but you don't want to play
half but and
and then
uh lose and then go well i'm not sure
why i lost except maybe my lack of
effort yeah is that what you're saying
yeah and that i just don't the phrase
calling somebody's bluff marriage is not
a game
it's something that you do together it's
not texas hold them you become one i'm
not i'm not calling anybody's bluff i'm
gonna figure out how
i can make this thing work on my end and
i'm going to expect the same of you now
with my spouse but if somebody's down to
throwing an ultimatum down a job that is
a fire alarm that there's all kinds of
crap going on inside your walls even if
you don't understand them
and you need to find out what that is
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you